My husband requested Biria for dinner,
which is one of his favorite Mexican dishes,
so I got started immediately.
That morning,
I started by searing my pasteurised beef roast on all sides
and used the fat trimming to make tallow.
Meanwhile, I made my chili sauce.
A variety of guajillo and California peppers,
onions, and garlic cooked in water
and then blended with lots of herbs like cloves,
cumin, and oregano.
After removing the pepper tips and creating my sauce,
I poured it into the browned meat
and strained out the seeds and any other particles
for a super smooth product.
This simmered all afternoon along with my beans,
which I cooked in bone broth.
Next, I started by making my masa,
first
by washing the corn I had cooked the night before and watering cal,
then using a Molino to grind into a chunky masa,
and lastly a matate for smooth masa.
Making tortillas without a tortilla press has been on my list of goals,
and I have finally accomplished it.
After five hours on the stove top,
my meat was soft and easily shreddable.
While my husband and children patiently waited at the table,
I constructed the birria tacos with chopped onion, lettuce,
raw cheese, and homemade raw sour cream.